s
blessures, ne souhaite qu'une
chose : retourner au combat.
- C'est un va-et-vient constant
d'ambulances militaires.
Pour chaque soldat soigné
qui repart sur une improvisée, e
est admis, marqué à vie par
la brutalité de la guerre.
Sacha nous dit qu'il a roulé
était au volant, est mort sur
le coup. Il avait 22 ans.
Il y a autant d'histoires
tragiques que de blessés
dans le sud de l'Ukraine.
Depuis la ligne de front,
on les transporte ici et
on les soigne sous haute
L'hôpital est plein,
de filmer dans les chambres.
Ils sont 5 ou 6 soldats
en silence, souvent après des
heures sur la table d'opération.
La médecine de guerre
se développe au rythme
des combats et elle fait
des miracles.
Ça fait trois semaines
que Vitaly a failli perdre gauc.
Une balle dans le
lors d'une embuscade,
rivière la nuit pour secourir
des confrères d'armes.
Il dit que les médecins se sonts
graves eet promet que
si on le répare à temps,rnera s.
Et c'est cette fot cette fot c,
selon lui, qui donne l'avantagee
ée russe.
Des hommes motivés qui pansenta.
ne se voient pas, mais qui
les rongent à l'intérieur.
nous a raconté qu'il est soigné
pour le coeur, rattrapé par
de la guerre.
"Une violence inouïe", dit Igor.
Lui aus
quand des éclats d'obus lui
ont déches nerfs
de l'épaule. Il était prêt,
mais il décrit des conditions
de combat absolument pénibles.
"Des journée entièresger, sans .
Des combottes, mais
on n'a pas le choix", dit-il.
Et lui
retourner au front, même si
ça veut dire qu'il risque,comme.
L'armée ukrainienne n'a pasdévt
puis qu'elle a lancé ses
contre-offensives dans l'est et
bien qu'elles leur coûtent cher.
Il baisse les yeu
quand il raconte avoir eu
dans les champs.
"Il y en a beaucoup trop, mais
plus comme avant."
"Il faut plutôt voir la guerre
comme l'occasion de survivre",d.
Radio-C